while biden's border crisis rages on a
dozen gop lawmakers decided to see the
surge themselves our next guest visited
mcallen texas as part of the largest
border delegation since the pandemic
began georgia congressman buddy carter
is here to tell us what he saw
congressman thanks for being with us
before we get into the details of what
you saw i'm curious was this the first
time you had been to the border or have
there been years in the past where you
got to see the crisis as well
now actually this is the fifth time
since i've been a member of congress the
last eight years that i've been to the
border the last time i was there was
about a year ago when president trump
was down there and i've also traveled
down there twice as a member of the
doctor's caucus to make sure the
unaccompanied children were being taken
care of well perfect so you have a lot
of context you have five trips to
compare the situation today
too so would you do so what did you see
today that is different from what you
might have seen in the past well
unfortunately i was hoping that i would
see
uh improvements but i didn't see any
improvement whatsoever still
overcrowding still the border patrol
agents are overwhelmed one of them
described it as being like working with
a bucket in front of a fire hydrant
don't send me more buckets turn off the
tap that's what needs to happen but
instead the body administration they are
just enabling this by essentially
ignoring the situation as we all know
joe biden has never been to the border
not as a vice president not as a senator
not as president and and he doesn't
understand he didn't he hasn't seen what
i've seen and what others who have been
down to the border have seen and that is
really one of the worst humanitarian
crisis in the world right now
yeah you you characterizing it as one of
the most you know one of the worst
humanitarian crisis in the world is
fascinating when you take into account
that now
the us is working with spain apparently
spain to help resettle migrants and ease
border pressure i don't i don't that
that so that is incredibly shocking to
me how does that even work spain is of
course an ocean away to help us deal
with this problem
yeah
and
you know that's really
just
the biden administration trying to
deflect blame and trying to to move us
off move us off of the target here
because those people want to come here
to america we are the land of
opportunity and they know that that's
why they want to come here we've got to
stop this and the way you stop it
according to the border patrol agents is
first of all you build the wall secondly
you keep title 42 in place thirdly you
enforce the remain in mexico policy and
fourthly and perhaps most importantly
there needs to be consequences for these
people who are crossing the border they
are breaking our laws and they need to
suffer the consequences of that yeah
absolutely
it doesn't seem to be any in sight to
this crisis that just keeps getting
worse congressman buddy carter thanks
for sharing with us what you saw on your
trip to the border
thank you